فعل رشا متبقي تقريبا ساعه ونصف على بدايه
هذه الحفله التي يحييها اثنا عشر فنان سبع
فنانات عربيات
والمتبقي خمس فنانين من ايضا همم العالم
العربي حيث ااه من مختلف الجنسيات العربيه
والفنانين كبار همم حيث تتزامى من هذه
الحفله ستبدا تقريبا بعد ساعه ونصف عند
الساعه العاشره
وستتزامن بكل تاكيد مع دخول السنه الجديده
هناك ايضا المفاجات تم الاعلان عنها بانها
ستكون لحضور هذه الحفله الاضخم وهي الاولى
من نوعها منذ بدايه موسم الرياض في هذا
العام بس اذكره لك الفنانين والفنانات
الذين يشاركونا ويحيون هذه الحفله تتحدث
عن نانسي عجرم اليسا واصاله ونجوى كرم
انغام ولطيفه و نوال الزغبي وكذلك همم
صابر الرباعي والكفوري كذلك عاصم الحلاني
وبهاء سلطان ووليد توفيق همم هذه الحفله
ستقام في مسرح محمد عبده ارينا والتي
وسميت بيتري ونايت هذه الحفله همم في اكبر
مسارح موسم الرياضه وتحديدا في منطقه
البوليفارد رياض سيتي في هذه المنطقه التي
كمل غناء او الاغنيه التي يمكن ان يؤديها
كل المطرب منها هؤلاء اعتقد انه ستكفي
قبله من او قبله منه اغنيه واحده هذا على
كبير للغايه
نعم رشا بالفعل يعني لو كل فنانه وفنانه
اخذ 20 دقيقه ونصف ساعه سيكون لدينا اربع
ساعات من الوقت فبالتالي لدى الحضور في
هذه الحفله وقت طويل جدا للاستمتاع به
وايضا استقبال العام الجديد بهذه الحفله
همم
الحصول على جميع التذاكر حتى اخر تذكره
نعم بالفعل وهذا ما كنت اود اذكره رشا حيث
قبل قليل كنا مع احد الاشخاص يريد ان يدخل
الى داخل بوليفارد ولكنه لم يجد همم
تدعكير فبالتالي هنالك نفاذ في كميه
التذاكر في هذا اليوم الكثير من الاشخاص
الذين بداوا يتوافدون منذ ساعه في هذه
المنطقه للاحتفاء
وللاستمتاع لاخر ساعات هذه السنه واستقبال
السنه الجديده عبر الذهاب الى المطاعم
المقاهي الكافيهات همم الاغنيه الموجوده
ايضا النافوره الكبيره وعدد من المسارح
المتواجده ممكن ترفيهيه كبيره جدا همم
يقصدها الناس في همم سواء كان همم
بوليفارد ريال سيتي او حتى بوليفارد وورد
الذي هو اصلا بوليفارد وورد يقيم همم كل
يوم منذ اسابيع همم العاب ناريه كل يوم
عند ساعه تقريبا 10